that's so funny where do we get Mexicans
America
[Music]
California experts are racing to save a
$15 billion airport that rapidly sinking
into the sea at an alarming rate 15
billion a airport that's sinking into
the sea what's what's a rate that's not
alarming good question I think just like
sinking in general is alarming right
holy [__] that's crazy what did they
build this on Swamp land or something so
as you would say in
Japan Japan yeah there's this that's
what the airport is sh it's it's
actually just right off the coast of it
and it's it has been open um for close
to 30 years right now uh as of now
millions of people use it every year
it's the closest international airport
to the cities of Osaka Koto and Kobe do
you know this one nope s sing katachi
but it's also however sinking into the
sea
basically the Kanai region nailed it of
Japan losing out was losing on on trade
to Tokyo and it was decided the place
needed a bigger airport but the existing
airport um was surrounded by suburbs
there's really no room to expand so and
then also the locals were like don't
build a fuing airport here please right
we don't need more noise um so then it
was decided they needed a new airport
allog together so they would create an
artificial Island to put the airport on
oh wow so you know like in China they
have a lot of these artificial Islands
as well like it it doesn't always sink
right but work to start uh this island
started in 1987 and by 1994 the airport
was opened and that's quick Japan got
struck with the great Hansen earthquake
in 1995 the airport was fine 1998 it was
fine when it got hit by a typhoon W but
over time they noticed that it would
start sinking as the weight of the
airport would push down in the soft soil
of Osaka Bay wow and it's like a wet
sponge right damn that's crazy and it
just keeps on continuously sinking based
off of the weight and they expect it
they expected it to sink by 5.7 M by by
the '90s and instead it went down 8.2 M
so it's that's alarming an accelerated
rate than they even thought scary yeah U
plus as people are in the airport right
you're you know you got little kids
jumping up and down that's accelerating
the rate of you got little kids you know
what I'm saying Japanese kids like to
jump people are jumping all over the you
got soul planes doing this on the tarmac
can't have that anymore how do you I'm
so confused like if it's sinking right
how do you put dirt under yeah that's
crazy is that what you're supposed to do
yeah you put dirt over and then put
another tarmac on top that's true yeah
you got to keep stacking T you know
what's
CRA like paint layers quite simple at my
old house you know there's a at the end
of the street there was a house that
could have didn't sell because it was
sinking so they did have a machine that
drilled to the bottom and they filled it
with dirt oh but I don't know how you do
that that's a house though I don't know
how you do that with a [__] airport
whole ass airport it's big boy too it's
a big boy is it kind of like getting a
spatula under a egg and then you lift
the egg up a little bit and you put like
oil and then you put the egg back bring
the spatula in yeah I feel like the
Japanese guys are going to figure it out
they will but that's kind you got to go
to Every Home Depot in the world and
just get every dude and go we got some a
big job boys we need you like the CIA
yeah you just stand side by side on a
count of three we all lift
up there like a Japanese recter going to
every home people in America there we go
all put the th go go go go go go the
guys putting the J in their sweating
dude oh man cuz we're watching these
guys bend the knees some guys knees are
like bent in I like that it's all just
labor work it's like there's no machines
just everybody's lifting from underwater
and then just going like this to
yeah holy [__] dude and there's always
one dude that's pretending to LIF not
doing [__] [__] the guy that can
scratch his nose the guy that's like
this hey dude how'd you do that hey
how'd you point at
me damn it's like I was taking arm War
down the stairs for a neighbor of mine
and like afterward he was like whoa
that's crazy I was like I took all the
[__] weight you little [__] boy I
was in the front dude you're walking on
the side yeah yeah looking around
stairs are always easy to expose who's
not
help say that was hard so they're
estimating it's going to take uh
billions and billions of dollars to fix
this problem why don't they just remove
it and build somewhere else cuz that
would also take billions and billions of
dollars you got to make a whole new one
so it's cheaper I like the idea of
layering TX to get to get a bunch of
Mexicans to lift you got to cross-hatch
them too you got to fly him to Japan
yeah well there's going to be a Japanese
recruiter I could see this presentation
they're like what what are we going to
do and then this is like I think the
only way is to get the Mexican they
built America you know and then they go
where do we get the Mexicans like they
just let a lot of in America and then
yeah they'll be a Japanese recruiter we
buy a
plane that's so funny where do we get
Mexicans America
California sick ass line one of the
problems do is that the airport like
different parts of the airport are
sinking at different rates like the
middle of the airport sinking the
fastest the middle like oh so it's like
a sinkhole yeah oh damn so planes are
going to take off like
this the first toilet bow style airport
yo that's sick or they just need to have
like [__] 20 drones and the drones
are just keeping the place from
sinking 20 that's it only 20 yeah 25
maybe bra it's Bart's brain it's like
it's like the shield helic carrier [__]
yeah it's a [__] Marvel Cinematic
Universe over here dude I saw three
helicarriers did you guys see that plane
crash that recently happened in Japan oh
yeah yeah yeah that was crazy sad uh two
one they had that commercial plane in
like a medic plane and then they went
off at the same time and [__] hit
like that the people in the medic plane
died like four F folks the commercial
one was fine but they had to do a quick
Landing right and then they had to do
those evacuation things while the back
was smoking oh my and then you see like
all these people getting out with
[__] flames and [__] and then the
plane just caught on fire who fault was
that air traffic control always yeah my
brother used to do ATC and he said that
near a near hit made him quit it's so
stressful yeah I heard that's one of the
most stressful drops so somebody made a
bad call and then they just both yeah
cuz then you're supposed to let them go
like one at a time but then they weren't
they were going at at the same time holy
[__] dude did you guys see the video of
uh there's a there's a a a pilot who's
like experienced right and he's talking
to lady in traffic control and he's like
hey I'm going to do like a short l or
whatever he says I don't know [__]
Pilot Talk and she like lectures him
about H that that's not that's not
correct or whatever you even got enough
oh cuz she like Googled it or something
she Googled it yeah she's like I Googled
it and like that's not what you're
saying like come on that's been poping
up my why Googl is air traffic control
fighting with Pilots they're like
actually you didn't clear the [__]
Runway so I'm going to report this and
they're like yeah why don't you go ahead
and report it then bud let me give you
my number yeah like do their [__]
talking to each other what's even
funnier than that is watching Air
Traffic Control simulator Gamers argue
with each other no dude those guys are
the best there's a game where one guy's
being an air traffic controller and the
other guy's the pilot and even they're
fighting no dude the guy who wants to be
the air traffic controller guy is a l
it's not even real and they're P
fighting really so they're just natural
enemies there traffic controller and the
pilot like Bloods and Crips huh
yeah pus that's that's like when your
little brother unplugs the controller
and plays the game like you're so you're
in a game but you're in the air traffic
control tower the other guy gets to fly
a [__] plane cuz it's like pirate
games and you get to tell him yeah
landed over there like yeah okay people
enter that game on purpose just to troll
the air traffic controller and they'll
just do whatever the [__] they want and
the guy's like no you can't do that and
like the guy just goes insane dude I'd
be buzzing the tower all day long all
day that drives him crazy I watch Top
Gun dude that drives those guys crazy I
watch top yeah dude that's so crazy that
one one guy's bad call it's like the
crosswalk lady and drivers we have this
uh one like crosswalk lady at taica
school she's like from New York and like
if she puts the stop sign they don't
stop where'd you learn how to drive the
zoo
did I like that it's it's like a G-rated
like expit I'm walking here there all
these kids yeah would you learn how to
drive the zoo what here you freaking
animal yeah these monkeys AR less than
a so kid friendly yeah dude I need that
game and you got to tell me that game
ste's you'll love it that's so great cuz
anytime you find people taking something
too seriously that's what it is they get
so mad they're like P can we get pilot
checklist please all that kind of [__]
it's so yeah dude yeah I'm 69 out here
dude dude I dude you'll love it wow so
have you guys ever been a air traffic
controller